mais thomas berteigne président de la
ligue des droits de l'homme dans le
xviiie arrondissement de paris
un bonjour et merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france à leur première
question qu'espérez vous de cet appel
lancé à à claire et dont on espère que
avec cet appel au défenseur des droits
qui puisse y avoir une réaction une
médiatisation aussi du sujet même si ça
fait ça fait ça on en parle on espère
que que je pouvais enfin le défenseur
des droits sera probablement écoute il
l'a déjà été par le passé notamment
quand l'avaient saisi pour un campement
en mai 2011 suite à un recours au
tribunal stratifie qu'on avait gagné
contre la préfecture d'île de france par
rapport aux conditions d'hygiène et
salubrité un défenseur des droits avait
déjà réagi avait déjà constaté aussi
l'absence de james abriter de conditions
sanitaires dignes dans les campements
donc on espère encore une fois qu'ils
puissent se positionner à nos côtés et
on espère aussi que cette saisine à ce
moment là puissent aussi rentrer comment
dire en coordination avec le nouveau
projet de marlène schiappa sur la
coordination qui elle va mettre en place
en ile de france l'a aujourd'hui le
gouvernement souhaite que les demandeurs
d'asile particules de france souhaitent
de créer 3000 places en résumant en
france pour héberger des demandeurs
d'asile est une des premières régions
qui va être désengorgée ce rallye de
france et il va y avoir une coordination
qui est mise en place la maintenance
janvier par rapport à ça les 34
associations qui ont signé cette saisine
ne sont pas conviés à 7 à cette
coordination alors que ça fait cinq ans
qu'on travaille sur le terrain en
maraude en équipes mobiles médicaments
et on aimerait bien que cette
coordination puisse se dérouler dans des
conditions correctes et qui respecte les
droits des exilés donc voilà on espère
beaucoup de choses on espère que ça va
enfin changer les choses ça fait ça fait
cinq ans que la situation est comme ça
que ça soit dans draka les world quand
on vient de le voir que ce soit à la
royale et malheureusement aussi en l2
donc ces trois régions ça fait cinq ans
qu'on est dans un processus répétées de
d'évacuation d'une tous les deux trois
mois on retrouve les mêmes personnes qui
sont effectués qui sont vomis dans des
gymnases qui ressort dans la rue ça fait
cinq ans que ça dure donc on espère
enfin qu' un changement qui va être
amorcées que défenseur des droits pourra
aider dans ce changement est justement
comment vous expliquez que le
gouvernement finalement n'a rien fait
pendant toutes ces années
aucune disposition n'a finalement été
prise
concrètement pourquoi une question on
aimerait bien qu'ils changent la presse
je pense qu'ils sont dans la stratégie
de ne pas faire d'appel d'air c'est ce
qu'il répète depuis des années ils sont
six dans une stratégie politique je
pense pas
certaines certaines thématiques de
l'extrême droite mais c'est pour ça
qu'ils vont pas bien qui ne crée pas
suffisamment place qui ne crée pas suffi
l'astuce théocratie stade suffisamment
grand pour prendre en charge
clairement c'est pour ne pas qu'ils
aient d'appel d'air selon eux justement
au gouvernement vous représentez vous
êtes président de la ligue des droits de
l'homme dans le 18e arrondissement mais
les ong et qui sont également
signataires de ce texte quelle
alternative à pourrez vous a proposé
bon on appelle à la création littéraire
conséquent avec une prise en charge un
conditionnel c'est à dire que là
aujourd'hui la prise en charge suite à
des évacuations se font pour un mois
deux mois après il ya des remises à la
rue souvent sèche parce que ces centres
n'arrive pas à orienter dans d'autres
centres donc voilà aujourd'hui on
aimerait bien qu'il ya un centre
suffisamment avec une grande capacité
qui puisse prendre en charge tout le
monde de façon suffisante avec
assistants sociaux des juristes des
psychologues que ce service soit prise
en charge par l'état et non pas par les
associations comme c'est le cas
actuellement où ses médecins du monde
qui fait les équipes msf qui font les
équipes médicales mobiles que ce soit la
distribution alimentaire d'autres
associations les équipes juridiques
c'est la ldh la cimade qui font ça vaut
ça que ça doit être tout ça doit être
dans un même centre doit être accessible
directement pour les exilés pour plus de
facilité dans un seul centre en ile de
france après qu'ils puissent assurer une
orientation soit en ile-de-france dans
des centres qui correspond au statut des
personnes soit en province dans d'autres
centres avec une capacité d'hébergement
dignes et parce que c'est aussi ça le
problème aujourd'hui parce que quand on
envoie des gens en région et qu'on les
envoie dans des hôtels sans prise en
charge sociale
forcément les gens vont revenir à paris
où ils connaissent de la communauté donc
déjà de base
il faudrait les centres de très grandes
jeu il a peu de capacité grand et
ensuite une prise en charge sociale
juridique à nice tu adaptes et danser
dans ses centrales et que ce soit en
capacité suffisant par rapport au nombre
qui est présent merci beaucoup en tout
cas d'avoir réagi avec nous sur rtl
france merci thomas berteigne président
de la ligue des droits de l'homme dans
le xviiie arrondissement de paris